[Musique]
participer aux JO c'est une expérience
incroyable c'est des émotions qu'on peut
pas vivre ailleurs il y a tellement de
compétitions mais les JO c'est quelque
chose à part j'essaie d'être très
j'essaie de de voilà d'avoir mon mot à
dire et si je suis performant j'espère y
être
pense à la médaille olympique je ressens
un peu des battements un peu plus forts
je suis complètement déterminée et je
suis en mode guerrière pour tout
exploser
[Musique]
c'est une armée qui prend corps qui se
prépare à vivre l'une de ses plus
grandes batailles pour gagner en France
une médaille olympique sur la base
aérienne 123 d'Orléans Brissy ils sont
88 sportifs de haut niveau de la défense
a participé à un stage de Cultura sur
militaire
du beau monde des champions d'Europe des
champions du monde des médaillés
olympiques et paralympiques réunis pour
renforcer leur cohésion de groupe un
indispensable à la performance sportive
cette immersion est l'occasion pour les
athlètes de rencontrer les aviateurs du
Loiret de découvrir leur environnement
parmi eux il y a Mona elle n'a que 21
ans lorsqu’en 2011 elle perd sa jambe
droite dans un accident de la
circulation
pour se reconstruire elle va nager nager
vite nager fort jusqu'à enchaîner les
performances
quelques années plus tard elle découvre
le handbike la nageuse semue à la
rentrée athlète de talents et décroche
en 2022 le titre de championne de France
est championne d'Europe puis intègre
l'armée de champion on peut être que
solidaire des armées qui sont en
opération que ce soit à l'extérieur du
pays ou à l'intérieur pour pour défendre
la France donc voilà puis j'ai eu
moi-même recours à
l'armée française quand j'ai vécu au
Liban et qui a eu la guerre donc j'ai pu
être rapatriés grâce à eux donc c'est
sûr que quand on m'a appelé qu'on m'a
dit tu pourrais intégrer l'armée de
champion en tant que sportif de haut
niveau
j'ai pas hésité une seconde et j'ai dit
oui tout de suite
on partage forcément beaucoup de valeurs
donc ne rien lâcher s'entraîner au
quotidien pour le jour de la mission ou
le jour de la compétition est au point
être performant ça c'est des valeurs
communes après forcément ils ont un
métier quand même beaucoup plus risqué
que le nôtre et ça ça se respecte ne
serait-ce pour ça
ensuite ouais derrière c'est il sait le
drapeau français le plus haut possible
et puis chanter la Marseillaise
[Applaudissements]
ces hommes consacrent une bonne partie
de leur temps alors discipline favorite
au hasard de notre visite nous
découvrons les rugbymen
les boxeurs depuis la création du
Bataillon de Joinville en 1956 le
ministère des armées poursuit une longue
tradition de soutien au sport de haut
niveau français
en 2014 la nouvelle politique
interministérielle des sports donne plus
de souplesse et d'adaptabilité dans le
recrutement et la gestion des sportifs
de haut niveau sur l'ensemble des
disciplines
ses athlètes forment l’armée de champion
et sont placés sous la responsabilité du
commissaire au sport militaire
commandant le CNSD le Centre national
des sports de la défense situé à
Fontainebleau les sélectionne avec un
ensemble d'acteurs heureusement d'abord
des experts sportifs du ministère des
sports du Conseil national olympique et
sportif français le CNOSF et puis pour
nos para raclettes du son équivalent le
cpsf et puis une fois que la partie
sport en s'inspirant de la vie du
ministère et des instances de
gouvernance du sport avec des athlètes
qui sont sélectionnés sur une liste
ministérielle et bien je me penche vers
mes spécialistes militaires du Bataillon
de Joinville ou de l'école interarmée
des sports
et là et bien je regarde leur profil et
bien évidemment je vais chercher des
gens qui sont volontaires pour intégrer
nos valeurs militaires et à partir de là
après un entretien qu'on aura une lettre
de motivation et bien on organise une
commission de recrutement d'avancement
et de reconversion de ces sportifs de
haut niveau et on les sélectionne
généralement on en prend un sur quatre
un sur cinq et se bataillon de Joinville
c'est aujourd'hui depuis 2021 35% des
médailles des Jeux Olympiques de Tokyo
c'est 50% en paralympique et en
olympique des médailles d'or des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de Tokyo
nous accueillons pratiquement à parité
45% de femmes athlètes et donc
55% d'hommes
je suis content de vous trouverez là
cette spécialiste du sang et du 200
mètres reprend progressivement ses
marques sur la piste après un congé
maternité c'est vrai que j'avais une
petite crainte au départ
à l'idée de devoir annoncer que j'étais
enceinte parce que par rapport à ce
qu'on a pu attendre sur les médias
récemment
au contraire ça a été très bien
accueilli et jusqu'à maintenant je suis
toujours accompagnée et toujours soutenu
autant enfin surtout humainement
avant d'intégrer l'armée de champion en
2019 carole a fait partie du pôle espoir
du cnfd désormais c'est en tant que
sportif de haut niveau de la défense
qu'elle s'entraîne pour les prochains
jeux olympiques avec des rêves de
médaille notamment pour le relais 4 x
100 à Rio on se fait sortir en Syrie et
à Tokyo on arrive en finale donc c'est
déjà magnifique en fait et l'objectif à
Paris ça serait de rentrer dans la boîte
donc dans le podium 1 2 3 pour moi cette
échéance là les particulières parce que
elle est sur Paris en plus de ça il y
aura les proches il y aura la famille et
c'est surtout sur cette échéance finale
que je vais m'arrêter
pour partir à l'assaut du mont Olympe
Carol va surtout de voir se confronter à
elle-même appréhender son nouveau corps
balayer ses doutes il y a des moments où
des douleurs sont survenues parce qu'en
fait dans mon cerveau j'ai toujours
intégré
on va dire
la technique de cours et tout ce qui
s'ensuit par contre le corps réagit
différemment donc au départ ça n'a pas
été facile de jongler entre mes
intentions et ce que mon ce que mon
corps va
interagir mais en fin de compte au bout
de quelques mois on a réussi à
rééquilibrer la balance et ça m'a
beaucoup mieux pour moi
l'athlétisme et le sport en général
c'est 90% du mental par rapport au
physique il faut jamais laisser tomber
faut jamais abandonner dans les moments
les plus difficiles et au contraire
c'est sur le mental que notre victoire
se prépare le mardi au lieu de faire des
séances courtes fera des
parcours Milan et finir par un long
donc là cette facilité de de
réponse à l'entraînement qui est qui me
permet d'avancer assez vite donc là là
en ce moment là elle est techniquement
ça va techniquement ça va
en termes de vitesse ça va comme je lui
disais à l'instant ce qui reste à
travailler et qui
à mon avis assez
[Musique]
on a pas mal de retard c'est la partie
résistance
pour être capable à nouveau de faire des
efforts longs et intenses la machine est
lancée Carole part en reconquête
elle aussi a des choses à prouver
feeling Rosie 21 ans fait partie des
nouvelles pépites de la boxe française
nous la retrouvons dans un lieu bien
connu de l'élite des sportifs hexagonaux
l'Institut National du Sport de
l'expertise de la performance plus
connue sous l'acronyme INSEP 28 hectares
au cœur du bois de Vincennes dédié à la
réussite
je mange à l'INSEP j'ai mes
entraînements NCF j'ai aimé j'ai mes
rendez-vous médicaux à nicef donc c'est
vraiment ici ma petite bulle mon petit
chez moi donc c'est important d'avoir ce
confort et sa propre chambre ou on peut
se retrouver lorsqu'on en a besoin c'est
important
en parallèle de ces entraînements
bicotidiens Stelline étudiait en
troisième année de licence STAPS option
Management du Sport si la boxe anglaise
fait partie de sa vie depuis l'âge de 7
ans elle est bien consciente de la
nécessité de se construire un après le
haut niveau est éphémère cruel parfois
l'athlète sort tout juste d'une blessure
au dos les jeux approche et puis les
blessures forcément on va en croiser
après c'est tombé pour mieux se relever
je le prends un peu comme ça ça me ça me
donne encore plus de détermination et
d'envie pour pour arriver à mes
objectifs forcément la vie n'est pas
facile tout rien n'est facile donc il
faut travailler d'arrache-pied pour
obtenir ce qu'on souhaite au fil des
tours de la boxeuse retrouve sa
hargne un combat intérieur qu'elle
entend gagner 2
on réfléchit plus on doit monter je suis
dans le coin j'ai demandé de monter
allez
au dessus de ça la jeune martiniquaise
veut s'offrir le droit de poursuivre son
rêve dans la catégorie des moins de 57
kg les poids plumes et c'est les points
serrés qu'elle se concentre sur ses
objectifs
peut compter sur le soutien de l'armée
de champion qu'elle a intégré en tant
qu'aviatrie en novembre 2022 il faut pas
oublier que le point financier ça reste
important parce qu'on peut se projeter
pour plus tard ça peut
ça peut nous apporter sur
la reconversion c'est demain on souhaite
rester dans l'armée et on a cette porte
d'ouverte et
et ça nous apprend à vivre comme des
adultes en fait voilà on a on a une
entrée d'argent on a un salaire le
principal problème qu'on peut rencontrer
quand on est sportifs de haut niveau
c'est de se dire comment je vais je vais
pouvoir payer mes factures et comment je
vais être à l'aise pour pour l'avenir là
avec un statut donc de sportifs de haut
niveau de la défense ils ont une solde
tous les mois donc du coup ils peuvent
subvenir à leurs besoins militaire juste
pour l'argent si on a signé pour être
pour être dans l'armée il faut savoir la
représenter aussi de temps en temps
apporter ce qu'on sait aux autres donc
moi je l'ai pas choisi juste pour le
plan financier si j'ai choisi pour
m'impliquer entièrement enfin pas
entièrement puisqu'il y a le sport à
côté mais dès que je peux pouvoir voilà
s'il y a une initiation et que je peux
représenter bataillon de Joinville j'y
vais
c'est lui c'est lui c'est grâce à lui
sur mon choix de d'être de vouloir être
militaire au sein du bataillon de
janvier c'est un parti grâce à Moreno
c'est Moreno qui s'est assis à côté de
moi ou à qui j'ai pu poser une question
mais comment ça se passe dans l'armée
qu'est-ce qui t'apporte comment on fait
pour intégrer et tout et puis le voir
avec sur les photos les réseaux sociaux
ça aide aussi donc au niveau des réseaux
voir que voilà il passe ces moments là
avec l'armée forcément ça donne envie au
total ils sont quatre pugilistes
militaires de haut niveau le résultat
d'une longue histoire entre la boxe et
le ministère des armées marquée par un
profond respect mutuel
à quelques centaines de kilomètres de là
au pays des flamants roses de la pêche
en bord de mer et au paraît-il le temps
dure longtemps sauf peut-être pour les
amoureux de vitesse
les matelots accès les poema retrouvent
leur peinture de guerre c'est à hier sur
la plage de l'Almanarre connue dans le
monde entier pour ses vents propices au
sport de glisse qu'ils vont retrouver
leur sensation après une semaine de
compétition internationale
[Musique]
tous deux issus de famille passionnées
de voile il découvre le kitesurf
adolescent aujourd'hui ils font partie
des meilleurs mondiaux et on rajoute un
foil à leur discipline
on est accroché à un espèce de
cerf-volant qu'on appelle une aile de
kite
qu'on dirige avec une barre et cette
barre est accrochée au caille par des
lignes et on a une planche un peu comme
une planche de Wake où on met nos pieds
et puis avec la force du vent et le
mouvement du kite ça nous fait glisser
sur l'eau le kitefoil on a la même chose
sauf que à la plage d'avoir la planche
rectangulaire plate on a une planche et
en dessous un mât avec un avion à cocher
qui nous permet de survoler au dessus de
l'eau et de ne pas toucher l'eau quand
on avance
en compétition ils évoluent entre 30 et
35 nœuds soit environ 65 km heure
parfois 80 à l'entraînement leur sport
est un sport à risque un sport extrême
on évolue dans un milieu qui est sauvage
c'est un milieu naturel la mer qu'on
connaît pas forcément donc il faut
vraiment être attentif aux conditions
météorologiques
parce qu'on dépend de ça si le vent
monte le vent baisse il faut adapter
notre matériel par rapport à ça donc il
faut garder une certaine humilité par
rapport à la nature souvent on se croit
un peu plus fort et des fois elle me
remet bien en place
tu peux essayer de partir un petit peu
plus tard que pour les mâle elle le fait
et après on échange
[Musique]
en 2024 le kitefoy fera son entrée aux
JO pour la première fois et tous le
savent les places seront chères
mais sous observation pendant plusieurs
épreuves et à la fin ils choisiront
qu'un Français et qu'une Française pour
aller représenter la France aux Jeux
Olympiques ça c'est pour la voile en
général il y aura qu'un bateau par
nation
et durant cette période l'objectif c'est
juste de donner le meilleur de
nous-mêmes et d'arriver au meilleur
niveau possible si aujourd'hui on est
aussi bien représenté dans le top 10
français c'est parce que on sait
travailler tous ensemble et
c'est ça qui nous permet de nous
dépasser et parce qu'on a besoin en fait
d'être entouré pour s'entraîner à
s'entraîner tout seul de son côté ça
peut par moment être bénéfique mais le
jour J on sera 30 sur les lignes de
départ et il faut savoir naviguer au
milieu de des autres donc c'est un peu
notre notre force aujourd'hui
Axel c'est quelqu'un qui ne renonce
jamais à aller s'entraîner qui est hyper
stable dans sa planification et c'est un
laborieux il aime aller au combat
travailler s'entraîner
je peux même dire que quand il était
petit il était hyper actif il avait
besoin de faire du sport tous les jours
sinon ça n'allait pas et ça se ressent
dans son style de vie ça se ressent
aussi sur ses performances parce qu'il
est très stable c'est le plus stable de
la régate et c'est ce qui fait que à la
fin il gagne souvent et puis son
engagement il a besoin de d'adrénaline
de pousser ses limites ce qui est un
petit peu le cas de peau Emma aussi pour
Emma elle aime bien
quand elle se met en mode guerrière là
elle va vite elle déchire tout elle a
pas peur de prendre des risques et
c'est vraiment une force qu'elle a
surtout chez les filles un mental qu'il
construise aussi avec et pour Axel
l'uniforme a été obtenu à force de
persévérance l'intégration l'armée des
champions donc au bataillon de Joinville
a été pas facile pour moi j'ai fait ma
demande déjà depuis 2016 il y avait
vraiment une motivation qui m'habitait
pour faire partie de cette aventure
et voilà donc je suis rentré dans mai
2022 j'ai fait mon processus de
d'intégration comme un militaire normal
et ensuite j'ai intégré le panthéon de
Joinville à Fontainebleau pour faire mon
inculturation militaire vous avez mis un
petit mot aussi sur la prépa physique là
première phase de régénérescence et
après se remettre un petit peu dedans
avant la régate pour essayer de
reprendre les bases de ce que vous avez
stabilisé durant la planif de l'hiver
surtout pas oublier de manger
[Rires]
la professionnalisation du kitesurf a
fait évoluer la préparation des athlètes
si avant
naviguer vite et intelligemment
suffisait maintenant ils doivent aussi
intégrer la préparation mentale et
physique dans leur programme pour
gratter quelques centièmes prendre du
poids de façon saine est aussi devenue
un objectif
nous dans notre sport il y a un intérêt
d'être lourd
quand on est rendu compte au fil des
années parce que dans notre sport en
fait on doit choisir une taille de Dell
de kite de cerf-volant comme on peut
dire et plus on va prendre une aile qui
est grande et plus on va aller vite donc
notre stratégie c'est si on peut tenir
la plus grande surface d'elle possible
et qui va nous donner énormément de
puissance et si on arrive à contrôler
cette puissance pour nous faire aller
plus vite
on peut gagner notre collection
sur ce chemin escarpé vers la victoire
chaque soutien compte pour dépasser ses
peurs et continuer à avancer
une motivation supplémentaire c'est
peut-être ce qu'est venu chercher Mona
dans le sud-ouest de la France à Agen au
48e régiment de transmission je vous
laisse lire votre rôle je vais lire le
mien
alors le rôle du parrain
donner une image valorisante de lui-même
de l'institution et de la formation
qu'il parraine devant des lycéens et des
représentants d'associations sportives
elle s'engage officiellement à faire
rayonner l'unité mais aussi à lui faire
découvrir son nouveau monde et le rôle
du commandant de la formation parrainée
donc le rôle de du 48e régiment
transmission dans ce dans cette charte
et d'établir un contact privilégié avec
le parrain et ce partenariat débute avec
la présentation de son équipement je
pars en vélo là j'ai 20 km donc le vélo
quand je dis le vélo c'est ça c'est un
handbike dans sa catégorie Mona doit
enchaîner 750 mètres de natation 20 km
de handbike et 5 km en fauteuil de
course
de l'effort avec des hommes en armes qui
comprennent son engagement
on a déjà quelques actions où je
pourrais participer des journées portes
ouvertes etc donc ça va être chouette
pouvoir les rencontrer faire encore plus
en plus connaissances avec vraiment les
gens qui travaillent ici au quotidien ce
qu'ils font etc aussi vont pouvoir
apprendre à me connaître au-delà de la
sportive de haut niveau vraiment qui je
suis depuis je vais pouvoir
éventuellement parler un peu de son
sport et puis faire en sorte voilà de
d'animer d'animer tout ça et des amener
avec moi dans mon projet de de jeux
paralympiques en pour Paris en 2024
je crois que c'est elle qui va se
préparer physiquement mais pour revenir
sur elle ce qui m'a frappé aussi c'est
la manière d'aborder la compétition qui
provoque assez différente d'une
compétitrice ordinaire quand on est par
athlète on se battre avant tout contre
soi-même pas contre les autres c'est ça
qui est assez beau et qui a beaucoup de
sens pour nous ici et c'est un message
qui sera assez fort je pense à passer à
tous les militaires qui ont besoin de se
surpasser eux-mêmes et pas forcément de
faire la compétition avec leurs voisins
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la compétition sera bien présente près
de 200 athlètes représentants 21 nations
ce sont donné rendez-vous pour un choc
sportif de haut niveau
les 24e championnats du monde militaire
de triathlon de Brive-la-Gaillarde sur
le papier l'équipe militaire tricolore
fait partie des favorites un statut que
les Français vont chacun de voir assumer
sur les différentes épreuves dans la
catégorie Elite les concurrents vont
s'affronter sur un format olympique en
entrée 1500 mètres de natation dans une
eau à 16 degrés vient ensuite le plat de
résistance avec 40 km de vélo et en
dessert 10 km de course à pied
ce sont les filles qui ouvrent les
hostilités cinq françaises sont sur les
rangs dont deux sœurs et deux membres de
l'armée de champion le maréchal des
logis chefs Audrey Merle et le sergent
Sandra Daudet
rapidement la française Mathilde
Gauthier prend les reines de la course
et sort en tête de chaque épreuve
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
derrière la compétition est rude
[Applaudissements]
impérial et selon tête le soldat
Mathilde Gauthier s'impose en deux
heures douze et 53 secondes juste devant
Audrey Sandra qui viennent compléter le
podium après une incroyable remontada
honnêtement il y a un moment donné je me
suis dit qu'on jouait pour la quatrième
place mais quand on a doublé du coup ma
petite sœur j'ai eu en visu assez
rapidement les deux finalement Paulina
climat c'est et Mayer et là je pense que
toutes les deux on a eu un petit un
petit coup de boost
après le triomphe des filles c'est au
tour des garçons de s'expliquer et à ce
jeu là le maréchal des logis le corps
est plutôt doué champion du monde longue
distance 2022 et sportive de haut niveau
de la défense depuis une décennie il
compte bien entraîner ses frères d'armes
dans son sillage
de la sortie d'eau les Français sont aux
avant-postes
[Applaudissements]
à la deuxième transition 4 tricolores
font partie du groupe de tête
à pied pierre le corps rattrape son
léger retard et finit la course aux
côtés de son compatriote le soldat
Nathan laisse man avant de faire la
différence avec 15 secondes d'avance une
course quasi parfaite pierre
il est très très intelligent dans sa
gestion de course et de la lecture de
course c'est à dire qu'au niveau
stratégique il s'est très bien le moment
où il faut attaquer le moment où il faut
essayer de se reposer
il analyse très très bien et c'est un
très gros point fort c'est un athlète
que j'admire à la fois pour sa force
mentale psychique son exceptionnalité
physique son élégance son humilité et
puis c'est un vrai Iron Man militaire
c'est un vrai soldat le lendemain les
jambes sont encore lourdes
pas assez pour entamer la détermination
des relayeurs français
Nathan ouvre le bal avec des Hongrois et
des Suisses prérend découdre après Célia
vient le tour de Pierre
le corps pour l'instant actuellement on
est exactement à
35 secondes sur les Suisses donc c'est
eux qui nous inquiète le plus voilà
pierre il va être se retrouver à être
tout seul à faire le vélo voilà on va
faire un manomano avec les Suisses et
après on verra sur la suite
le couteau entre les dents allez allez
tu vas la chercher
[Applaudissements]
et à la fin c'est toujours la France qui
gagne
dans cette course comme au quotidien les
quatre chercheurs d'or ont pu s'appuyer
sur leur solide family militaire
sans faille et
je le dis pas souvent mais bon vu que
j'ai l'occasion de le faire maintenant
ça fait maintenant trois ans que je suis
remise de la maladie Drive et clairement
l'armée m'a pas lâché pendant les quatre
ans où j'étais au fond du trou alors que
j'ai perdu énormément de mes sponsors
donc
j'ai pu revenir à ce niveau donc je les
remercie
en organisant ce championnat la France
assume son statut de pile et au sein du
Conseil International du Sport militaire
mais pas seulement je suis satisfait
aussi parce que cette ces épreuves ont
permis à nos à nos champions de
s'entraîner peut-être pas au plus haut
niveau mais un très très bon niveau en
vue aussi pour eux à titre français de
préparer les échéances de Paris dans un
an l'idée c'est d'identifier à chaque
fois ce qui a pas marché ce qui a marché
et puis de d'avancer comme ça pour
essayer d'arriver vers une course plus
ou moins parfaite le jour où on
l'attendra donc c'est comme ça qu'on
avance c'est clairement c'est des
passages importants et même obligatoire
pour progresser
pour Audrey Sandra et Pierre Brive est
une première étape ils devront encore
avaler de très nombreux kilomètres à la
nage en vélo ou à pied afin d'atteindre
Paris en 2024
[Musique]
et c'était une superbe un superbe
événement et voilà donc on part tout ça
avec des très beaux souvenirs
au revoir les athlètes que nous avons
rencontrées rêvent tous de marquer
l'histoire de leur sport en intégrant
l'armée de champion ils ont rejoint un
groupe soudé autour d'un même objectif
olympique un projet fou le projet d'une
vie
[Musique]